las úlceras por presión también llamadas
escaras son regiones de piel que se
lesionan cuando se sienta o se acuesta
en una posición por mucho tiempo estas
heridas ocurren con más frecuencia en
áreas donde los huesos están cerca de la
piel que incluyen talones tobillos
caderas coxis o codos
la presión constante en una de estas
áreas comprime los vasos sanguíneos que
suministran oxígeno y nutrientes vitales
a la piel
sin una suficiente cantidad de flujo
sanguíneo las células de la piel
finalmente mueren y se forma una úlcera
por presión las úlceras por presión
están categorizadas por grados de
severidad una úlcera por presión de
etapa 1 está enrojecida inflamada y no
se vuelve pálida cuando se aplica
presión en ella una úlcera por presión
de etapa 2 aparece como una ampolla o
úlcera abierta es posible que el área
que rodea la úlcera esté enrojecida e
irritada una úlcera de presión de etapa
3 implica una pérdida de piel de grosor
completo que se asemeja a un cráter y se
extiende hasta la capa de grasa que se
encuentra debajo de la piel la etapa 4
es la más severa una úlcera de etapa 4
es una herida de grosor completo que se
extiende hasta el músculo y hueso
subyacente
para prevenir la infección de una úlcera
por presión
el médico limpiará la herida usando agua
y un jabón suave o suero
si su herida es severa su médico les
brindará o extraerá quirúrgicamente el
tejido muerto de la úlcera por presión
para proteger e hidratar la herida el
médico posiblemente la cubra con una
venda especializada